[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Рік тому ми вперше сюди приїхали. Тут усе було зарослим — дуже багато чагарників.
[Закарпаття, с. Пацканьово,
Екопоселення]
Подивилися — вирішили, що все-таки,
тут варто жити і треба жити.
Є у нас хлопці з Івано-Франківська.
Дівчата — з Дніпропетровська.
[Володимир Вашко
Засновник Екопоселення]
Міша — він з Виноградівського району.
Я місцевий, я з Ужгорода приїхав,
прожив там 15 років.
І  зрозумів, що кожна людина
має жити в сільській місцевості.
Там, де є чисте повітря, там, де є чиста вода,
і там, де можна вирощувати для себе чисту їжу.
Оскільки ми вегетеріанці,
то для мене особливо важливі:
свіжі фрукти, овочі та молочна продукція.
У нас є невеличкий парничок, десь 5 на 20 метрів.
Ми там вирощуємо огірки, помідори, зелень.
Є ще таке прислів'я: «Хліб — усьому голова».
Усі люди, які живуть на Закарпатті,
їдять хлібний продукт.
Бо хліба справжнього немає.
Це замінник.
Тому ми створили невеличку пекарню,
де випікаємо за дідівськими рецептами
хліб на заквасці.
Так пекли хліб ще п'ять тисяч років тому.
Ще сімдесят років тому так пік мій дід тут.
Є борошно, яке відважується, просіювач.
Борошно просіюється через сито і насичується
киснем для того, щоб краще хліб підкисав.
І тістоміс.
Процес виготовлення хліба займає близько шістнадцяти–двадцяти годин.
Якщо на звичайній пекарні
процес триває дві-три години,
то тут в п'ять-шість годин довше.
Тому ніхто не хоче пекти такий хліб,
бо багато затрати сил, а прибуток маленький.
Усі женуться за грошима.
Мій дідусь звідси родом, з Пацканьово,
а моя мама — із села Лінці.
Перші роки життя я прожив в Лінцях.
Пас кози.
Тому в нас кози зараз є, бо я пив
лише козяче молоко, коров'яче не міг пити.
Багато дивився вестернів, мріяв про коней.
Тому в нас тепер є кози і коні.
[сміється]
Мрії збуваються дитячі.
Це породисті білі козочки,
але поки що в нас їх небагато.
Ми хочемо змішати нашу породу
із швейцарською породою кізочок.
[відповідає козам по-козячи]
Хочемо вивести таку породу кіз,
щоб вони були стабільні до нашого клімату,
і були породистими.
Будемо пробувати їх схрещувати.
Насправді, в селі є багато чим займатись.
У мене в голові багато ідей.
Перша моя освіта фінансист,
мені подобалось вчитись на фінансиста.
Це така спеціальність,
де ти маєш спланувати,
куди можна вкласти кошти і
отримати максимальний прибуток.
Я тут бачу десятки напрямів, чим можна займатись.
У нас тут, наприклад, прекрасна глина.
У нас є готова піч, в якій температуру
можна підіймати до п'ятиста градусів.
Ми можемо робити глечики, посуд.
Все дуже просто.
Потрібна просто людина,
яка буде любити це робити.
У нас такої людини зараз немає.
Я можу продовжувати: це збирання трав,
вирощувати спеції,
робити косметику натуральну.
Це безліч [можливостей].
Найважливіше: щоб людина займалась тим,
що любить.
Якщо людина робить щось з любов'ю,
то ця любов буде відчуватись в тій речі,
яку вона виготовить.
Є Пацканівська сільська рада,
і я тут — сільський депутат.
[сміється]
Був в області депутатом, а тепер у селі.
Такий у мене «стрибок».
Планував у Верховну Раду — депутатом,
а опинився в Пацканьові.
Сільським депутатом.
[сміється]
Але мені подобається, я не жалкую.
Я зробив прекрасний вибір,
і кожного дня переконуюсь,
що він був правильним.
Тому що, ми усі тут щасливі,
ну, принаймні, — я.
[сміється]
[Оператор
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Монтаж
Дмитро Безвербний]
[Музика
Іван Лузан]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]